like
yep you know
i've spent uh
almost all my waking moments with this
family since tuesday
and what i know is
they collected children parents they
collected
but they want to see change meaning that
no one else
who is suffering from a mental health
crisis
uh should be met by ill-trained
ill-prepared ill-equipped
police officers that means we want to
see
every police officer in the city of
philadelphia
outfitted with non-less than legal
methods we want to see them outfitted
with tasers
so that you don't have to wait around
and call for a seat for city training
that you haven't listened to the case
they didn't even call for one
but just like with darren lee right
there's another man with mental health
issues documented
mental health issues uh who was shot by
police
who had to call for a cit trained
officer to the scene
and before that officer responded they
shot him as well
okay that's right here in the city of
philadelphia uh
in 2019 so that is what the family
would like to see happen will you file a
wrongful death plan against the city of
the police department
uh well i can tell you a wrongful death
occurred uh whether we'll be the ones
following the claim
that remains to be seen quite frankly um
you know
right now the family made funeral
arrangements on today
to bury uh their their son their brother
you know uh that is any business
ownership reality
a wrongful death occurred right and so i
expect if someone
commits success they'll be arrested a
theft i expect that
if you do a hit and run someone will be
arrested for a hit so if you
call someone's wrongful death if the
logic flows
that there will be a wrongful death suit
what are your expectations of the
investigation in terms of
what it will reveal and what will happen
afterwards i'm sure you've seen other
high profile cases around the country
with police involved
what does that make you feel less
optimistic about something
happening uh no no one does it for me
because of where we're located we're not
in kentucky
thank god
we're in the progressive city and i'm
getting ready to find out at the same
time youthful here
whether that was just a bunch of
rhetoric or whether there's some
veracity and some truth to it
there's been a lot of campaigns and
wages uh in this town when people are
running for office about being
progressive
and changing things and changing the
mindset and changing the landscape
there's been a lot of that talk right
and so what will happen now before your
eyes in mind
is that we will find out whether that
was just a bunch of hype
and they sold us a bill of goods or in
fact
if there's any merit and truth to it
during
the litigation of this particular map we
will find out
rosie's definition of rookie all right
new to the force
uh and you might uh imagine that a
person
moves to the floor doesn't have a wealth
of experience in every scenario
and so let me be clear i'm not saying
that disparage that officer
everyone has to start somewhere but
that means that perhaps you should be uh
better trained
to deal with these sorts of
circumstances especially especially
when you have multiple calls there
should have been a supervisor
listening to that saying you know what
that sounds like something
for me to respond as opposed to this
particular unit that has
a newbie officer uh assigned to that
controller
i don't know but i'll tell you this not
enough experience
to pull back say you know what this is
uh perhaps beyond my skill set at the
moment and this is not disparaging them
but i want to be clear about this please
don't misspoke this is not disparaging
but this is calling you know
following the truth the truth i know
what i saw and i know what i heard
and when you see these officers and
their body language
the way in which they performed in that
particular moment
that wasn't uh a level of sophistication
or professionalism i'd expect that a
class a one city could be part of it
no we've been even asking for that and
and trying to
you know respect their process you know
so i wouldn't have to refer to them
this way but but but you will know who
i'm speaking
because uh the officer who has
uh tattoos on his left forearm
you'll hear it and the reason you know
he said shoot him is eight because your
ears will not deceive you
and then your eyes will neither because
you shot
at um
um
let me say this to you uh
i don't know how accurate these numbers
are so you have to
accept this in the spirit in which i
mean it but when we checked i believe
the annual budget for the police
department
730 million dollar budget now i get
you've got a lot defending them i
understand
what the average cost of behavior if i
want to walk into a store myself the
average qualification
i believe is 700 which
okay depending on the style the model uh
et cetera
if you were to outfit the remaining
officers who are not
tit trained with tasers which is about
approximately 2 000 offices
you will spend about anywhere between a
million and a half and three million
dollars
making certain and putting priorities
okay a million and a half to three
million dollars would be making certain
and putting priority
on less lethal methods ensuring that
your officers with the training and that
equipment would only implement deadly
force
when absolutely necessary and the reason
we know that is because you would have
given them
a step in between without respect
between
you've hamstrung your own police
officers so i
hear members of the fop i hear
uh jonathan hear what he said you know i
hear that
and uh you know quite frankly i think it
was
well disgusting however one thing rings
true
one thing rings true when he says you
know i i feel for the opposite
in some respects this family does too
because those officers
didn't have to be put in that position
if they had the proper equipment
and their proper training on that point
we agreed
most anything
oh
oh
uh
stop
i heard you say justice you want justice
for your family what does justice mean
like a person scared of a mouse
you didn't have no feelings of of
life itself that's a dangerous person i
mean
we cry we laugh that's feelings
you know i mean that's that's emotional
feelings of life itself
when you don't have that type of
situation you're very dangerous
to society and everything and this mayor
he's a coward he's either in any kind of
man
for the people he would come down here
and get off his ass
and come down and talk you know i mean
you know
that ain't he that ain't his kid he
didn't got to bury nobody
he don't know what pain is suffering and
we want
the people elected him and it's always
party but they want to play with
themselves and wake up and smell of
coffee
because life is serious now i mean it
ain't about color
it's about respect and once you take the
respect people don't have trust and
respect
you have a serious situation you know i
mean
the future situation don't vote by
gasoline on fire you put it out
you know what i mean and he for him to
be a man
he's less than a man to me i'm a man
you want to act like you're a sis he
played with dog baby that's on you
but come on down here and talk to me
just like we is i mean
he didn't lose nobody so he don't know
damn
he don't get he don't care about no
compassion
we we cry all the dog they know about a
bunch of drunks and alcoholic
they label us and that's the way it is
you know i mean
you call a kitchen black or the kettle
wherever you want
that's a reality check you know i mean
so when it hit close to home to somebody
else
pain ain't nothing we played with you
got to suffer
you know i mean and respect is due to a
captain adult
has anybody from the city reached out
apologize
for this if they apologize i should be
able to fly
the family aware of the protest on
i'm sure
november 7th which is uh
two saturdays from now between
uh nine and eleven
nine a.m is the dealing that's close to
11 and the service will begin at 11 a.m
and this will be at the church of
christian compassion
okay that's where they were on tuesday
evening
the church of christian compassion
saturday november 7th
between 9 11 is the healing
and the service begins at 11. uh
you know listen like the party remarks
will do this
that man is rude that man is freaking
bad
you might pick out of things that sound
like you like you know
sound bites you like you call them their
power you pick out the sound by choosing
the best suits you but here's the truth
in that
that man is hurting deeply in a way that
my very colorful imagination can't
conceive
to be present and when i say prison i'm
speaking about looking with your eyes
listening with your ears watching your
son that you fired with your woman
shot down broad data
in front of you his mama and his wife
forgive him for the name
don't put more on that than you should
don't give him more weight than you
should
and that is walter wallace uh he's a
junior as well
walter wallace
oh well listen you know people nowadays
they put more vows in syllables i can't
help it
right but
[Music]
okay
yesterday yesterday she was too her
labor was a new phone yesterday
her labor was a news born yesterday and
uh she's eight pounds
eight pounds even when she was born uh
healthy
by all accounts um and there's that
you know yes mom is doing okay
there was a whole conference with her
she's doing all right
no no we don't
you know but right so leading up to uh
the death of the d
about a minute some change quite frankly
uh if you watch the entire video in
three after
school seven eight minutes
one officer left the scene because he
assisted with scooping the body
and you know doing an emergency
transport uh to the nearest hospital
so uh he left for that reason uh which
was
a good reason to leave the scene um and
the other officer stayed on the scene
and then reported to uh a superior what
a superior
dinner in fact
a
body yes sir
no no yeah it wasn't a compilation
two separate videos two separate angles
we want to thank everybody uh for coming
i encourage you uh
when you watch the video to listen for
uh some of the things that i told you
that you hear
um you know and thank you for coming and
showing some support for the family by
trying to get uh this story out with
questions that you were able to ask
uh i will ask you lastly to keep them in
their prayers um i know how this works
the headlines will change tomorrow and
then we won't be talking about what the
wallace you know going forward
and actually keep them in their prayers
uh and quite frankly
uh to the extent that's necessary i'd
like you to keep your office in their
prayers too
uh because there's trauma on both sides
of this particular situation
as well and probably
but what you know how would you
characterize the the city's
mental health services systems and how
they respond
to this family oh true
[Music]
[Music]
coffee without walking by somebody in
this town without
talking to them everybody you know what
i'm saying
it's a problem in this town some people
have issues
some cities have issues
[Music]
some people some cities have issues with
homelessness
and some cities have issues with mental
health and then criminal cities
have the double crop which is mental
health and homelessness because those
two are
intricately woven together this city has
a
this is this city has a very vast
mental health crisis they really do they
really do
and i'm not talking about mentors that's
the ones that we see out here on the
streets
you know uh not properly wearing the
proper clothes for the for the occasion
you know talking to themselves not those
folks
i'm talking about undiagnosed mental
health
it is rampant through this house and
officers
being first responders are the ones that
you expect to come into
uh first touch with those people
so you've got to train your police
officers listen
when you arrive to a scene you have to
you have to give them different levels
of experience and expose them
to different things so they are prepared
to deal with those scenarios
when they see them i'm not saying turn
them into clinicians
right you don't have to make them mental
health experts but you have to expose
them
so that their first thinking isn't
do you know how many
one or one thousand it doesn't matter
because
every call they are expecting three
things
professionalism experience and to have
their
issue remedied by those first responders
they are not expecting murder
murder murder on their city street by at
the hands of the people they called
would you call a murderer to your house
to help you of course you would
you caused who you thought would help
you so how do those two conflicts
um
dropping somebody off taking them into
getting real tuned and then all of a
sudden they're homogenous yeah right
and what i would say is uh
there's a there's a revamping that sort
of needs to take place
for today's purpose right i'm not on
what you say
about you know mental health and and and
the like
i'm talking very specifically about the
philadelphia
uh police department's response
when they are patrolling our city
streets and dealing with us
in a collective fashion i'm just going
to say this to you i have a hard time
believing
let me just say this to you that if the
officers responded
in many of them and chad came outside
and chad was experiencing a crisis
i have a very difficult time believing i
will not accept it you couldn't get me
to
that if chad came outside and was in
crisis and had
a knife for a box cutter
that you would immediately victory gun
chad down
i can't accept it so what i'm saying to
you is
there needs to be by the police
department
additional training and i don't want to
use that word so lofty i
pretend to do he's training training
specifically on keeping people
alive keeping them alive
do not cause their death at your own
hand i'm not suggesting that there are
times when what lethal force that report
has to be used i'm not suggesting that
this right here walter wallace
this was not one of those times
right
uh and and perhaps i am being naive in
this moment
but i sincerely hope there is a uh
expansive investigation
one that has an eye on reform okay
what i mean is people have to
investigate what happened here
with an eye toward this can't happen
again
right and if you do that i think that we
will arrive
at the right decision whatever that
becomes thank you everyone
thank you very much
sorry guys
i